unfortunately general hospital has let
me go
because of the vaccine mandate general
hospital star steve burton confirms on
instagram he was let go from the
long-running abc soap opera after
refusing to get the coven 19 vaccine
burton goes on to explain he did attempt
to be exempted from the vaccine mandate
i did apply for my medical and religious
exemptions and both of those were denied
burton says the whole thing is
disappointing but this is also about
personal freedom to me i don't think
anybody should lose their livelihood
over this the 51 year old actor has
played jason morgan on and off since
1991. how can i help
i need to make a phone call despite
being let go he shares his gratitude for
his time on the series with that being
said you know me i'll always be grateful
for my time at general hospital
i love it there i grew up there i grew
up with some of you
so i'll always be grateful and i believe
that when one door closes multiple doors
open
that's always been my perspective as for
whether steve would ever consider
returning to his character i am excited
to see
what the future brings and maybe one day
if these mandates are lifted i can
return and finish my career as jason
morgan
that would be an honor and if not i'm
going to take this amazing experience
move forward and be forever grateful but
burton isn't the only general hospital
star to be fired over abc's reported
vaccine mandate actor ingo rademaker who
played jasper jacks jacks also refused
to be vaccinated against the coronavirus
as a result rademaker's last general
hospital episode aired this past monday
so you can make this happen today yes
but i strongly advise that you don't do
it because carly's being reasonable and
sometimes you just need to compromise i
won't compromise on justin's safety i
think i've said that already back in
june burton co-hosted et and he couldn't
help but gush over his longtime career
in daytime tv
steve you've won two daytime emmys
previously but never as a lead actor
what would this mean for you you know
being in daytime for
25 plus years yeah and to still get a
nomination it's awesome and i just tried
every day to do do the best i can show
up early and uh just be as professional
as possible and give it my all every
single day
[Music]
you